[Musique]
aujourd'hui face à vous toute l'équipe
de la chasse aux trésors cette émission
qui passe le dimanche après midi vers 18
heures sur antenne 2 en tête de cette
équipe le producteur jacques antoine
jaccoud êtes déjà venu nous expliquer
comment se passer cette émission comment
vous l'aviez imaginé comment voulez vous
réalisiez bien maintenant j'aimerais que
vous nous présentiez vos principaux
collaborateurs car comme toujours il en
manque quelques-uns oui bien sûr le
rythme il manque même un des
collaborateurs essentiel c'est le
cameramen parce que vous verrez je
pensais les téléspectateurs l'ont fait
mais alors ils mentent pas vraiment là
il sera différent d'un au courant des
vues au cours de l'émission qui joue un
rôle très important s'appelle jean yves
le maner alors mais a bien entendu il ya
philippe gildas philippe de dieuleveult
2 philippe que c'est un peu compliqué
surtout pour des gens qui doivent se
parler au téléphone avoue philippe louis
philippe sétois philippe oui je suis moi
aussi j -c phillips et philippe on n'a
pas osé les débaptisés ensuite il y à
jean luc noël qui est un institut
assistant qui procède au repérage à ça
tout à l'heure ainsi que rené denis les
réalisateurs jean jacques pasquet et
claude savarit bien alors philippe
gildas va être le premier qui je posais
un certain nombre de questions parce que
vous êtes celui qui qui qui fait se
poser le plus de questions de
téléspectateurs on se demande d'abord
pour quelles raisons vous êtes sans
arrêt en train de discuter de chercher
vos papiers sans jamais regarder de
téléviseurs je connais la réponse
devrait quand même une fois de plus que
vous le disiez la section le téléviseur
le nouveau avec moi même où les
concurrents qui sont avec moi mon n'a
pas l'image nous sommes les seuls à ne
pas avoir l'image au fond est ce que
vous croyez qu'on pourrait dire que
cette émission de télévision au départ
et lorsque vous la l'enregistrer n'est
qu'un jeu radiophonique pour un peu oui
pour le pour les candidats et pour
moi-même ça se passe exactement comme un
joueur adulé pour philippe de
dieuleveult de la même façon d'ailleurs
puisque nous travaillons lui avec le
casque sur les oreilles et moi avec un
retour soit la plateau comme dans un
studio de radio et nous nous entendons
plus ou moins
d'ailleurs c'est un autre problème parce
que c'est souvent très très loin et je
me souviens de certaines émissions en
afrique du sud ou bien aux américains ou
les liaisons été assez difficile parce
qu'en plus il ya des problèmes de
décalage horaire et vraiment on ne voit
donc rien puisque techniquement ce
serait pratiquement impossible de
classer coûterait des milliards et c'est
pas du tout le but de l'opération
donc impossible de voir l'image en même
temps donc nous nous sommes les seuls à
n'avoir que la liaison son et un son qui
n'est pas toujours fameux si bien que la
moitié de mon travail a consisté à
essayer d'écouter et de traduire et
notamment pour les non seulement pour
les téléspectateurs
mais surtout pour les concurrents qui
sont dans les mêmes conditions coin et
qui en plus ont le gros désavantage est
obligé de lire de rechercher de penser
et ça paraît idiot à dire comme ça mais
c'est très difficile de d'écouter
quelque chose de difficile d'entendre et
de lire et de suivre sa propre pensée
dans un sens vous êtes surtout
intermédiaire entre dieu le veut et les
candidats alors que vous jouez vous avez
le droit de jouer au cours de cette
cette émission je le droit de jouer dans
la mesure où je ne vois rien je suis
donc exactement la même condition que
les gelées
le couple qui joue mais en plus je peux
jouer parce que je ne sais rien non plus
je ne sais je ne connais pas même les
nids ce ne serait pas drôle
si je fais là c'est l'énigme et je crois
que je pourrais même pas faire
l'émission à ce moment là parce que j'ai
je pourrais pas qu'à l'émission si je
connais c'est l'énigme parce que je ne
pourrai pas les aider du tout donc je
serai un simple relais mécanique
je serai très gêné j'aurais peur de
l'est
de les conduire dans un mauvais dans une
mauvaise direction
alors que l' avantage de ne rien savoir
c'est qu'effectivement ça donne envie de
jouer et de gagner avec eux et de les
voir gagner
quels sont les impératifs de cette
émission vous ne faites pas ailleurs
fixe je crois ça ça doit être un
problème tout de même vous et de
l'enregistrer au moment où il fait jour
ça ça je crois que c'est un autre
problème je sais que jacques a déjà
beaucoup répondu la team je crois qu'on
peut leur dire une fois de plus bien que
c'est une émission qui est diffusée en
différé mais qui s'enregistrent vraiment
dans les conditions du direct
ensuite on ne fait que mélanger les
images tournées des deux côtés c'est sur
le plateau à paris et avec philippe de
dieuleveult et son équipe sur le terrain
donc on va mélanger ensuite c'est le
seul travail c'est à dire qu'on mélange
deux images mais dans la durée réelle ça
a été enregistré en une heure ça se
tourne exactement comme une émission de
direct
et alors le résultat c'est
qu'effectivement avec le décalage
horaire et bien quand on s'en va en
arizona on a neuf heures de décalage
donc les gens vont nous voir à 17 ou 18
heures le
dimanche mais en fait on a très bien pu
enregistrer à 23 heures le soir parce
que ça correspondait la meilleure heure
pour le soleil et pour l'équipe mais mes
camarades vous expliqueront dans quelles
conditions ils déterminent la bonne
heure de tournage
est ce qu'on en a fait d'autres plus on
s'en va vers l'est puis on tourne tôt le
matin c'est dans l'autre sens les autres
avertissent que vous avez vous êtes
quand même un petit peu tenu d'attendre
que tout se passe bien techniquement sur
le lieux extérieurs à l'étranger les
jeux les vraies difficultés mais là
encore c'est pas mon problème à moi
c'est pas mon problème animateur c'est
le problème de toute l'équipe les vrais
c'est bien pire pour les producteurs
d'ailleurs déjà qui est à côté
man show man plus de crayons en bois que
moi du souci les fois parce qu il nous
est arrivé quand même de d'avoir la
liaison cinq minutes avant l'émission ça
se passait à l'autre bout du monde
et puis d'avoir une rupture de liaison
téléphonique était un simple petit pépin
téléphonique
mais il faut six heures pour le réparer
or six heures quand ils sont en place
soleil par 40° au zimbabwe c'est une
catastrophe
de notre côté nous on peut attendre six
ans pour faire c'est très agréable vous
vers les césars des angoisses du
producteur mais vos concurrents ils
doivent quand même c'est un métier de
jouer presque elle pour la télé mais
c'est un jeu quand même et je crois que
tous les concurrents nous avons vu
jusqu'ici joué vraiment or certains sont
un peu plus nerveux
or on a vu une dame effectivement qui a
failli fait son mari pendant toute
l'émission parce que ça se voyait
pratiquement elle prétendait que c'était
de sa faute si elle allait perdre
elle a fini par perdre d'ailleurs et
et on a vu une autre qui s'est effondré
à la fin d'émission on a vu des hommes
qui étaient incapables de parler
effectivement pendant une émission mais
ça c'est l' angoisse du jeu c'est vrai
je crois pour tous je sais c'est pas le
sait pas le plus dramatique je pense que
le plus difficile effectivement celle
angoisses de l'équipe qui réalise et qui
à établir à chaque fois cette
performance assez incroyable qui
m'étonne moi toujours c'est que déjà on
sait bien qu'en télévision radio où on
peut avoir des pépins sur un kilomètre
de distance mais quand ça se fait par de
tels relais par un simple téléphone et à
six sept ou huit mois j'admire beaucoup
ici c'est aussi l'équipe il ya qui
réalise à chaque fois est le producteur
qui a eu l'idée un peu dingue à mon avis
de de tenter ce pari à chaque émission
spéciale c'est un pari qu'ont pu perdre
à chaque fois mais c'est quand même une
idée super allait super bien et comme
allant là comme joueur puisque je suis
autant jouer en qu'animateur sur sa
formidable
philippe de dieuleveult vous vous êtes
celui qui est ailleurs qu'il est à
l'étranger
ce que j'aime aussi beaucoup et qui joue
aussi beaucoup parce que je le précise
encore il ya très peu de gens et je les
présenterai tout à l'heure qui sont au
courant de l'énigme vous vous partez là
bas vous ne savez rien comme lorsque je
monte dans les commentaires c'est pour
aller se mettre en place pour la
première image je l'appelle alors déjà
en place qu'est ce que ça veut dire je
pense que les producteurs choisissent à
un paysage qui soit quand même assez
agréable oui à voir parce qu'au début
d'émission savait que les candidats
cherchent dans les bouquins qui sont un
petit peu perdues donc dans ce cas là on
a en démarrant déjà une très belle image
du d'hélicoptères bien mais moi je
montre un hélicoptère et puis je
découvre complètement les hélicos viable
disent aller à tel endroit j'y vais avec
le plus grand plaisir ce que maintenant
plus vous êtes bien écouter ce que vous
demande philippe oui alors égalé le plus
voilà alors bien écouter cet agrément à
gros problème parce que les liaisons ne
sont pas toujours très bonnes c'est vrai
et on tue les sages et le bruit
d'hélicoptère qui est quand même assez
infernal
je dois m'occuper de pilote de la carte
éventuellement lui ni boussole de
vérifier si le caméraman su bien
derrière si la casse était bien dans les
dom et aux fans parce que bien sûr dans
le mato scops elle n'y est pas il faudra
à son la coupe est un petit peu la risée
interrompu filet vouliez dire quelque
chose tout à l'heure
oui non je voulais dire que les dés
les premières émissions étaient ils ont
un petit peu pour tout le monde une
grande aventure
la tendance est toujours grande aventure
vous cite une ambiance dans
l'hélicoptère qui est fantastique parce
que jean yves le maner vous le disiez
jacques antoine sahler est formidable
mais il ya eu quand bruno delattre par
francis simon et thierry pouget on va
les voir tout à l'heure quand on a un
petit film sur un nouveau tournage en
fils je vais vous demander ce que vous
vous êtes vous êtes angoissé inquiet
serein tranquille parce que tout de même
présenter ou plutôt courir ce tout au
long de leur gestion sage et très vite
je ne suis pas angoissé parce que c'est
pas compliqué ce qu'on me demande on
demande d'obéir d'entretenir ce n'est
pas ce beau défi c'est vrai je vais je
montre dans l'hélicoptère aller à tel
endroit je regarde la carte joker
pilotes ont dit vrai ça me semble
évident moi je serai présent non ici
n'était pas sourd ça sera plus mais il
est souvent source est-ce que quelqu'un
vous avez eu peur parce que tout le
monde avait des endroits où on vous
attend pas toujours on vous fait faire
tout de même des balades dans des dents
des dans des lieux un petit peu
impressionnant
enfin je pense que mon caractère est
fait pour pour ce jeu moi je m'amuse je
m'amuse beaucoup et j'ai envie d'aller
justement là où je ne sais pas ce qui va
se passer je lis de dire tout à l'heure
vous êtes un ancien la course autour du
monde sait cela et qui a été repêché
dans cette émission vous étiez déjà au
journal sur antenne 2 quand je travaille
tous les gens disent tous d'image depuis
trois ans brooke bien maintenant je
voudrais demander aux assistants et qui
ont un rôle très important sur cette
émission de me dire un petit peu comment
ça se passe d'abord la question qu'on se
pose toujours c'est nous quand on est
devant noté dans notre récepteur tout
est fait à quel moment commencez-vous à
travailler sur une émission je te parle
un peu plus que rené parce qu'il a un
peu et l'impact de gorée
vous faites la même chose oui c'est à
dire que rené s'occupe de l'équipe qui
travaille avec claude savary et que je
m'occupe de celles qui travaillaient que
jean-luc pasquier qui partira ensuite
sur le tournage
notre problème c'est de d'aller sur
place de repérer
les lieux où vont se dérouler les
missions à partir de lénine qui aura été
préparé à paris avec jacques antoine
c'est donc d'aller sur place et d'être
sûr que tout va fonctionner que on
pourra se poser à tel endroit et que les
lieux correspondent bien aux textes
préparés c'est vous qui monte le jeu de
piste sur place en quelque sorte une
préparation du jeu de questions pour
vérifier que tout ce qui a été imaginé
par jacques antoine et ça ça correspond
bien à l'arrêt l'horizon l'image qu'on
avait à paris
là vous faites donc avoir un premier
voyage bien avant l'émission bien avant
l'émission pour aller sur place avec
leurs fins les choses qu'on a réuni à
paris on a réuni dans les livres et
c'est toute une documentation mais ça
correspond rarement à ce qu'il ya sur
place il faut donc souvent arranger un
petit peu et puis revenir avec jacques
en reparler avec jacques et puis à ce
moment là les autres sont prêts à partir
est ce que c'est à ce moment là que vous
déposez le trésor absolument déjà la
personne n'est venu le nom d' par hasard
non c'est pas encore arrivé chaque fois
pour que ça n'arrive pas bien et vous
faites la même chose mais la rai que
jean-hugues avec donc je fais équipe
avec claude savary et donc c'est en
général j'en ai ne l'a pas dit mais
c'est un mois et demi deux mois avant
que les émissions ne se réalise vraiment
qu'il faut donc aller dans le pays pour
vérifier que j'aurais vous me préciser
tous les deux le jour de
l'enregistrement de l'émission dont vous
vous êtes occupés vous n'êtes jamais
là-bas vous êtes la marsa d'abord m à
paris nous sommes avant tout un ami de
jacques antoine sur le sur le studio
avec donc ses serres les candidats qui
plus tard alors que vous deux les
réalisateurs au contraire vous partez
avec l'équipe qui est à l'extérieur à
l'étranger alors que de savoir et
j'aimerais d'abord que vous m'expliquer
ce que cela représente comme
organisation comme travail pour un
réalisateur d'être sur le point
extérieur par rapport aux studios
d'abord je sais que vous m'avez préparé
pendant le week-end un petit dessin les
jeudis vous nous manquiez pour qu'enfin
on comprennent clairement je vous ai
préparé un petit dessin parce qu'il peut
nous on dit souvent qu'un petit croquis
vaut mieux que les grands discours pour
vous expliquer justement répondre à la
question comment ça fonctionne et est ce
que je vais faire sur place avec
l'équipe technique
si vous voulez symbolisée ici de ce côté
ci du dessin nous avons paris le sur
paris avec philippe et les deux
candidats et du côté sur ce côté ci de
l'image j'ai marqué l'australie pour
bien marquer que nous sommes loin
et vous savez convaincre et loin qu'on
va l'autre bout du monde et là il ya
l'équipe extérieur symbolisée par
évidemment l'hélicoptère et philippe de
dieuleveult
alors si dieu le veut vous avez déjà
remarqué dans les émissions il a une
espèce de pot a reconnu pascal évoqué
son cas il une petite boîte noire sur la
poitrine avec une antenne c'est un
émetteur récepteur de radio
lorsqu'il parle dans son micro cet
émetteur récepteur envoie sa voix dans
un
relais radio qui se trouve dans un petit
avion léger qui vole au dessus de lui
qui fait des ronds au dessus de lui
parce qu'en plus de l'hélicoptère vol
l'avion qui est un relais un relais
radio sanaa de cet avion la voix de
philippe va partir vers un point haut ce
que nous appelons notre station de
basket une grande antenne que nous
installons sur le lieu l'émission disons
dans un point élevé pour obtenir la
meilleure liaison possible au point de
vue radio et à cet endroit là au pied de
cette antenne
eh bien nous avons un téléphone tout
bêtement un téléphone et ce téléphone
il est relié au studio à paris et c'est
à la grande salle à la grande astuce
c'est qui ce passe un jeu au téléphone
au téléphone
bien entendu philippe de dieuleveult ne
sait pas trop ce qui se passe à paris si
ce n'est que parce que vides gildas est
en revanche film shaft voir rien il ne
sait que v8 mais par contre à peine
lorsque cette voie qui est passé par son
petit émetteur l'avion la station relais
de base et la ligne téléphonique alors
elle qui peut nous ramener depuis
l'australie par exemple sur ce dessin
jusqu'au sud de boulogne est bien là
arrivent ici dans un contenant un
haut-parleur et philippe gildas et ses
deux concurrents en entendant bien par
ce haut parleur
c'est vrai que le renouveler de tout si
c'est vrai que j'aurais dû ajouter tout
à l'heure que le l'une des grandes
difficultés
effectivement c'est que lui d'une part
ne voit pas d'un même pas idée de la
tête qu'on les concurrents et il va
découvrir les concurrents le jour où
l'émission est diffusée sur antenne 2
c'était à moi qu elle est tournée
une semaine où trois mois peu importe
mais il est court il les voit même pas
les téléspectateurs et nous en plateau
tiers les candidats vont voir les images
en même temps que moi à la télévision
quand ils iront gagner ou perdre mais
nous n'avons rien vu à voir absolument
rien vu plein de saveurs et comment vous
rendez vous sur les lieux du jeu
je vais vous surprendre on y va en avion
au niveau en avion mais avec un avion un
peu particulier parce que nous louons un
petit jet
ça semble un peu dayraut d'état mais en
fait les cons sont bien fait c'est quand
même la chose là la plus haute à moins
onéreuse pour transporter à la fois tout
ce modèle vous voyez sur l'image
maintenant ces stations relais de radio
la station de base radio car si le
matériel et wayne simmonds les gens ce
qui concerne le cameraman et lobe du
magnétoscope et le petit relais radio de
philips dieu le veut la station de base
et le relais radio qui sera dans le
petit avion qui va survoler l'ensemble
de l'émission c'est quand même beaucoup
de matériel c'est pratiquement 700 kg de
métal alors nous embarquons tout ce
matériel et l'équipe technique dans ce
petit gadget vous le voyez il est 5
heures du matin au projet on va partir
et toute cette équipe par pour un pays
lointain
en général elle n'a jamais
découverts ou connus avant elle ne sait
absolument pas ce que sera li ning ce
que sera le présent à chercher aux parts
dans la nuit en plein brouillard pour le
bout du monde
évidemment on disait tout à l'heure il
manque un certain nombre de vos
collaborateurs certes l'émission ce sont
ces fameux homme de l'équipe technique
qui est sur place à l'étranger alors
vous avez très gentiment à porter un
film où vous nous les présenter les uns
les autres
j'aimerais qu'on les voit maintenant oui
c'est un film qui a été fait par nos
amis de l'audio fine la télévision
suisse et qui nous avait filmé un jour
voilà pour la chasse au trésor alors
c'est peut-être je crois le moment de
vous montrer à la fois ceux qui sont
devant la caméra et derrière la caméra
ce que vous ne voyez pas alors il y a
tout d'abord bien entendu le pilote
d'hélicoptère les pilotes d'hélicoptère
c'est jojo projet qui est suisse puisque
nous sommes à nation et qui avec son
hélicoptère va nous emmener partout les
candidats le demanderont merci jo nous
avons évidemment philippe de dieuleveult
le reporter lui vous le connaissez bien
vous le voyez à toutes les émissions
il est l'homme qui court l'homme qui
cherche les trésors pour les candidats
mais avec lui il y a deux garçons très
important c'est ce qu'il faut l'image il
ya jean yves jean yves le maner que vous
voyez d'habitude au début de l'émission
que je vous présente avec sa caméra et
nous avons patrick simon patrick simon
qui lui est en charge de tout ce qui est
le francis immo qui est en charge de du
de tout ce qui vit des audi med cup
alors dites vous que lorsque vous voyez
philippe courir eh bien il ya derrière
jean yves et francis qui courent eux
aussi derrière et ils sont ils sont en
plus chargées de cette caméra et se met
à scop alors eux aussi l'espace sportif
pour eux n'est pas une petite affaire
et lorsque nous avons fini avec l'image
est bien il ya maintenant le problème du
sur le problème du son c'est la liaison
entre l'hélicoptère terre à philippe de
dieuleveult partout où ils se trouvent
et le sio de paris avec les candidats et
philippe gildas et bien cette saison est
assurée par patrick qui lui assure tout
ce qui est liaison radio avec une
station de base qui se trouve là
aujourd'hui à savièse au dessus de la au
dessus de la région de sion et entre
l'hélicoptère et la station de savièse
kiss à qui elle est liée à paris par une
liaison téléphonique normal
nous avons un avion un avion relais pour
permettre que la lisons surface toujours
bien entre l'hélicoptère et cette
station de sa vieillesse est dans cet
avion qui est piloté par petter pétri
suisse comme le pilote d'hélicoptère
dans l'avion de paix terre il ya une
station radio relais voilà tout ceci
tel qu'il se présente c'est un système
assez lourd mais fiable et qui nous
permet chaque semaine doit être dans un
pays différent tout autour du monde pour
faire cette chasse au trésor
mais un jour n'a d'ailleurs en suisse
nos amis de la télévision suisse avait
un deuxième hélicoptère et ils ont filmé
notre hélicoptère pendant toute
l'émission d'options ils ont
littéralement suivi comme des chiens de
chasse pendant les 45 minutes du jeu à
sion alors vous voyez l'hélicoptère et
sur son aire de départ prêt à partir
avec philippe le pilote et le cameraman
jean yves le merrer et francis si
monumenta scop
ils sont partis ils montent à près de
problème d'altitude avec ce petit point
blanc qui monte au dessus du barrage
c'est l'hélicoptère il franchit de
barrage de la grande dixence est
maintenant sur les ordres des candidats
il se rend vers un autre lieu qui je
crois va être le château de valère dans
la vallée au pied de ce magnifique
massif des alpes alors envoyé la caméra
de la caméra de jean yves le maner qui
filment en permanence car la caméra
n'arrête pas de tourner n'arrête pas de
filmer pendant toute la durée du jeu et
on arrive à proximité du château de
valeurs ou les candidats ont demandé à
philippe de dieuleveult atterri pour
essayer de quémander d'avoir quelques
renseignements sur l'histoire de la
région pour essayer de vous on se trouve
le trésor
ce que ne verront pas les quelques 100
millions de téléspectateurs qui à
travers le monde suivent la chasse au
trésor cela pourrait s'appeler les
coulisses de l'exploit
un exploit qui se renouvelle chaque
semaine dans un pays différent
aujourd'hui c'est la calédonie qui a été
choisi une publicité inespérée pour le
territoire
9h30 à magenta philippe de dieuleveult
s'apprête à partir pour le mans kobe
c'est là que commencera l'émission trois
trésors seront à trouver mais
l'animateur n'est pas dans le secret ils
sont d'ailleurs très peu nombreux à être
au courant c'est luc chevalier qui a
préparé d'énigmes et qui était le
conseiller tout au long de la
préparation de cette émission
préparation qui a duré quatre années
rien n'a été laissé au hasard dans le
producteur même la plume si l'équipe
venait à se poser en tribu avec philippe
de dieuleveult à cameramen dont la tâche
n'est pas facile
un technicien l'hélicoptère a été
aménagée spécialement pour l'émission
tout au long de son déroulement un
cessna survolera l'appareil il sert de
relais radio entre l'église
partage et le poste de commandement
s'est installée dans de nouvelles tours
de compose de magenta d'hélicoptères de
la gendarmerie est toxique en cours
philomène avec lui une moto qui pourrait
être portée utile à philippe 12 août
lorsqu'il sera quelque part dans la
chaîne
la première énigme a trait à la mine de
carola philippe de dieuleveult doit
retrouver le pic d'un pionnier qu'il n'a
pas d'autre indication il comme survole
la tribu de saint louis
il décide de se poser pour demander à
quelqu'un de l'aider nous sommes ici en
pleine émission et il n'est pas possible
à notre reporter d'image de s'approcher
afin de ne pas perturber le déroulement
[Musique]
le chef de la tribu accepte de servir de
guide et montent à bord de l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à vingt mille kilomètres de là dans un
studio l'antenne de à paris deux
candidats de nationalité suisse dialogue
en direct puissant voir les images
les images on se rend calais plus tard à
paris là bas il est minuit trente et le
cerveau se trouve dans la tour de
contrôle de magenta le producteur est en
relation constante avec harry l'équipe
sur le terrain et le cessna les
candidats n'ont su que quelques minutes
avant l'émission que la calédonie en
serait le thème mais il se rend bien des
difficultés et nous trouverons le
premier trésor qu'après seulement 22
minutes
il restera à peu de temps pour la
recherche des deux autres essais de
justesse qu'ils découvriront la deuxième
énigme à bord d'une épave pour chiens
l'une est la nuit
attention c'est une folle aventure
pendant une heure donc on est tous
tendus pendant une heure on donne le
maximum c'est l'aboutissement de quatre
mois de travail de quatre mois de
négociations pas toujours facile
tout est arrivé à être prêts au jour j
voilà moment à la minute prévue
et puis c'est la magie du direct car on
travaille en direct
il n'y a pas de montage cette émission
dure une heure et elles surgissent
pendant une heure alors un peu déçu
quand même parce qu'on avait deux
candidats j'aime beaucoup la suisse est
un pays merveilleux
on n'a pas une chance on a eu des
candidats qui n'étaient peut-être pas
dans le coup faut expliquer que était
minuit et demi quand on a commencé cette
émission ici en nouvelle calédonie était
minuit et demi à paris les candidats
devaient peut-être fatigués ils avaient
peut-être voyager en train je ne sais
pas pour venir enfin bref il n'était pas
dans le coup ils ont mis beaucoup trop
de temps à réagir et chevalier qui a
préparé cette émission avec moi je crois
qu'il était lui aussi déçu que moi on
avait tellement envie de montrer ce
joyau il nous a tellement vendu la
nouvelle calédonie on est tellement
devenu amoureux de la nouvelle calédonie
bah on est un petit peu déçu
parce que ce que je fais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui peut le faire bon ben j'ai
été choisi pour le faire tant mieux très
bien à tremblay pour moi mais il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes qui
peuvent donc tu peux faire ce que je
fais aucun problème va se dérouler la
prochaine chasse aux trésors manacor
pays bas nous repartons sur sur paris et
puis fin janvier on va prendre un petit
peu de repos pour les fêtes
fin janvier et bien nous allons sicile
au maroc en espagne et puis après les
partons à cuba et aux états unis
ces démissions deviennent de plus en
plus une grande aventure c'est un c'est
plus un quiz qu'on regarde amérique
c'est un game show grand spectacle c'est
l'idée de jacques antoine c'est de faire
maintenant des jeux non plus faire des
petits jeux comme les j'aime beaucoup le
chiffre net mais c'est un petit jeu la
chasse au trésor c'est un spectacle la
culture et du spectacle
or là les candidats nous ont remis dans
le cadre d'un petit jeu des bêtes et
stupides et c'est dommage parce que
philippe avait envie de donner l'énergie
qu'il a dans le ventre et et il a été
[ __ ] par des gens qui ne sont pas des
show men
[Musique]